-Denis, welcome to the show.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Thank you -- Thanks for being here.
You're one of the most sought after filmmakers on the planet.
"Dune" was such -- I don't even know how --
What a beast of a movie. I don't know how --
Even watching ten minutes,
I'm like, "How did you do any of it?"
Don't tell me, but it was amazing.
My question is, if you weren't making movies and --
and brilliant movies -- what would you be doing?
What career would you be doing if it wasn't for film?
-Whoa. It's a good question.
I'm not as --
I'm not talented like Questlove, having multiple talents.
So I think that -- One thing, I had always a plan B.
-Yeah, you did?
-Yeah, I -- it's -- I think I could be a baker.
I could be a good baker.
I love the concept of "people need bread.
You make bread. People buy bread."
There's something very -- I love this idea.
And I'm serious about it. -Really?
-Yeah, yeah. -"Do I want to be that?" Yeah.
-Yeah. I want to be that guy.
-"Dune," as we've seen, is such a big film,
and it takes so many years of work that goes into this.
But what people don't know is you --
This took you almost 40 years, actually kind of
working on this, if you know what I'm talking about.
-It's an old dream. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I read the book when I was 13 years old.
My best friend, Nicolas Kadima, and I, we were, like --
Let's say we were on the nerd side of things.
[ Laughter ]
-The nerd side, yeah. Okay. -Yeah.
And we were -- we were, like, dreaming about making movies.
We didn't have any camera, so we were drawing movies.
So -- And we were both in love with the book.
And I remember doing some -- some -- Oh, here we go.
-Yeah, some storyboards. -Yeah.
-This is when you were 13 years old.
-Yeah. -You drew this. Can we zoom in?
-I didn't -- I didn't -- Nicolas drew them.
They were inspired by -- by "Dune," yeah.
-Look at that. Did you use any of these shots?
-There -- There's some --
There's some one that are similar, but --
-That -- that's insane. That's crazy.
-It's an old dream. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I also will say -- Hans Zimmer did the score.
It's -- It's almost like it's own character in the movie.
-Absolutely, absolutely. It's like a psychedelic dream.
And what he created is that he was obsessed
with the idea to create new sounds, new instruments.
And I know for true that he made some raids at Home Depot,
buying pipes, things, and created instruments
to create new ways of expressing himself.
And -- And he -- he went back with it.
It created a bank of sound like that
and recording voices and things with voices.
-Because it's set in the future, and he's like, "If it's in
the future, we have to make a futuristic..."
-No violence in 10,191.
I mean, he wanted something
that was coming from another time, from another world.
-Yeah, I also heard that you scored some points
because you -- you came up with bagpipes
should be in the movie somehow.
-Yeah, that -- It's just that there's a scene...
for those who saw the movie where the Atreides are landing.
And I was a -- There was something missing.
There was something, but I wanted to have some glimpse
at the culture of the Atreides,
and I woke up in the middle of the night
suddenly saying, "Bagpipes."
And... -Wow.
-Lucky enough, we --
My first assistant, Chris Carreras,
didn't panic and brought the bagpipe on set.
And then I think I gained Hans Zimmer's respect.
He accepted that the bagpipes
will exist in 10,000 years from now.
That was his concession.
-Because it's a tricky instrument, yeah.
-It's -- A friend of mine, Joe Walker, we did the movie.
He said, "You know what is the definition of a gentleman?
Is someone who can play the bagpipe
but actually don't do it."
[ Laughter ]
I'm French-Canadian. -That's a good line.
-Yeah, I'm French-Canadian. It's not my joke.
It's a British joke.
-It's a great -- It's a great joke.
Yeah. I thought it was phenomenal.
And I'm so happy that you came here.
We asked you if you wanted to come talk to us,
because we're big fans over here, so...
-Merci. Thank you. -Thanks so much.
I want to show everyone a clip. Here's a peek at "Dune."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-It's confusing.
I thought I saw my death, only it wasn't.
I know a knife is important. Somehow.
Someone will hand me a blade,
but I don't know who or when or where.
♪♪
Some things, though, are crystal clear.
I can feel it.
-Denis Villeneuve. -Merci.
-"Dune" is on digital and available to stream on HBO Max.